if there really is gonna be a stargate
reboot what are the chances that one of
our favorite characters general o'neill
played by richard dean emerson could
actually make a return
this is scitrek your sci-fi tv a movie
channel
i've done a few stargate videos recently
and one of the things i get constantly
is i get asked
will richard dean anderson reprise his
role as general o'neill
or
i get the comment it's not stargate
without richard dean anderson so forget
about it well let's get stuck into this
could rda actually make a return so as
we all know in 2005 richard dean
anderson did take a step back from
stargate he carried on a reprising role
and appeared several times throughout
the last two series of the show but
really
was a big character
he did come back for stargate continuum
and really did play a starring role in
that and my god i loved it but he really
decided in 2005 like i said to become
much more of a hands-on dad
he wanted to be there for his daughter
and really stargate took a bit of a back
seat
now i gotta say i respect the decision
he made even though
god i missed general o'neill with all
the rumors the stargate is going to
return
on amazon
what are the chances he could reprise
the role well brady's been doing several
podcasts on this companion site that
he's on
he has done this read-through of this
new script generated by an ai
and it's gotta be said even though
amanda tapping daniel jackson and others
appeared and did a read-through of that
script
one person well actually two people were
really missing teal wasn't involved
and general o'neal but richard dean
anderson did do a little cheeky one
minute intro video in only the way he
can but he really didn't get involved
however he has announced that he is
going to be appearing on the podcast
with brad wright soon
what will he be talking about you one
day i'm going to get to that in a minute
because i think his appearance on this
podcast
is for a reason
but let's get back to it the chances of
him returning
we've got to remember his his daughter
now is an adult so his reason for
stepping away from stargate has now
grown up
but he's 70 years old
now we do have to remember that a man in
his 70s is not a surprise used to be
even though it doesn't seem to stop
people becoming president
it really
is a ripe old age he's not going to be
the general o'neill we know and love
but does that mean he couldn't appear in
stargate at all no of course not i
should say i have a little bit concerned
about his health once or twice over the
last four or five years he does seem to
gain weight and lose weight quite
dramatically he did get a little bit of
a chunky monkey sorry rich i'm sorry
but you did in recent times over the
last 12 months or so he's lost a lot of
that weight
possibly anticipation of a promised
return for stargate there's actually
they'll have a lot of charity work that
he's involved in even though he hasn't
appeared in any movies or tv shows for
the last few years he does keep really
really busy he does a lot of work with
the waterkeeper alliance which is a
charity really working hard to eliminate
um pollution in water around the world
he's also involved in several other
environmental except to be honest too
many to mention environmental charities
and you know if you if you really do
love stargate and richard anderson i
implore you to go and have a look at
some of these charities and and maybe
give a little bit of your hard-earned
money
i think the least we could do with
stargate fans is maybe support that
and to be honest one of my favorite
charities make a wish foundation that i
actually do give regular donations to he
is really involved in and has actually
received awards from the charity for his
good work
it's also got to be said that he doesn't
actually need the money
if if financial
that there is no financial need when it
comes to routinely announcing he was
executive producer of stargate don't
forget um he appeared in the show for 10
years
macgyver was a very popular tv show
before that and actually he was an actor
from pretty much late adulthood
his estimated worth is over 30 million
dollars um and the man that's that's
that's a decent nest egg for going into
retirement
but i would say mentioning the r word
he's asked quite a lot in interviews
have you retired from acting and he
always says no not really i'm just being
a dad for a bit
he does actually sound a lot all the
time in interviews like he would love to
come back and actually i think a reboot
of stargate would be the perfect
opportunity but let's be honest that's
not going to be as a major character not
a week in week out character anyway
but
maybe
as a recurring character as a four-star
general
maybe
to
support and
work with general carter that brad
wright has already hinted at
so
if amanda tapping does come back and is
the leader of a new project then i
actually think that general o'neill
could appear occasionally
in those moments of crisis to maybe be a
shoulder and maybe
to give that wise advice
two minutes i think that would be
perfect richard answered we'd get him
coming in every so often with his wise
cracks and just the the aura that is
general o'neill but
realistically that's the most we're
gonna get
so i mentioned earlier richard nansen
appearing on the podcast for companion
why do i think he's doing that well i
think like i said in a previous video
that brad wright is really trying to put
some
pressure on amazon i think he's got in
mind a project for stargate but now
amazon is sort of pushing its way into
mgm and talking about wanting the
project to be a lot bigger i think he
maybe feels that the project is slipping
away from him and he needs to get the
fans on side so that he can regain at
least an element of control on the new
show when it is green lit
in that case
who better to get on side and who better
to get on the podcast than richard dean
anderson
so it's going to be really interesting
to listen to this podcast when it is
released because i think it will really
give us an insight in what brad wright
is thinking
and if this is a call to arms to the
fans it will be done subtly but if it is
i think this interview will be very
telling because i think it's going to
give us a massive insight into what is
planned and what is coming for the
sleeping giant of sci-fi
our favorite show stargate so it's a
simple question will richard dean
anderson return to stargate
i think it's possible
but i honestly say i don't think it's
likely and if he does appear i think
it'll be in quite small parts i honestly
think it'll be few and far between
appearances
but that relationship between carter and
o'neal is going to be there still
she in a moment of crisis would turn to
perhaps a four-star general o'neill and
in those situations i could see that it
would be very easy to write in several
cameos and let's be honest he's going to
want it because i honestly believe he
loves the show just as much as we do so
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification really helps us out you can
join us on facebook and you can join us
on disco to talk to all like-minded
sidetrackers and links are in the
description also you can now join the
channel
and you know you can get these videos 24
hours before everybody else
um if you if you really really need it
that badly um a small contribution to
the channel as well really helps me
produce more content and hopefully go to
that next level
it also keeps my wife off my back
because if i'm making money on my silly
little hobby she won't motivate me quite
so much in the meantime stay safe i'll
be back really soon and thank you for
watching
[Music]